going in style is directed by zach braff
and stars Michael Caine Morgan Freeman
Alan Arkin and and Margaret and is the
remake of the 1970s movie of the same
name about three older guys who have
been screwed over by their bank
they've lost their pensions and they
decide to rob that very bank and comedy
ensues as the three of them try to learn
how in the world they would pull
something like this off I went into this
movie not really knowing what to expect
just knowing that this is directed by
Zach Braff and now he's making a movie
that seems a little more studio friendly
and he has more projects lined up and
I'm excited to see him working again but
mostly I was there for the three main
actors these guys are legends Michael
Caine and Alan Arkin are in their 80s
and Morgan Freeman is like 79 they have
been acting for a long time and this is
easily the best part of this movie
seeing these three together performing
their chemistry is amazing you feel like
they've been friends forever which their
characters have been and so I had a
pretty big grin on my face for a large
portion of this movie just because of
these three actors and their incredible
body of work and the fact that all three
of them are together they all show
themselves to have a really good sense
for comedy and I found myself smiling
throughout a large portion of the movie
it also has two pretty good small minor
supporting roles from Keenan who I grew
up watching Kenan and Kel and
Christopher Lloyd in a role in which I
haven't seen him this funny in quite
some time he plays basically the worst
case of Alzheimer's you could have and
he really sold it he was actually really
great I think the funniest scene in the
film was the first time they tried to
steal something because they figure
we're not going to go big at first we're
going to try to do something small-scale
so they go to a supermarket and try to
steal some food to make dinner and just
watching Michael Caine Morgan Freeman
and Alan Arkin trying to steal minor
produce goods
there's something very entertaining
about that there's a great moment where
Michael Caine and Morgan Freeman are
staring at each other through a line of
cans and they have some dialogue it was
actually fairly funny I was surprised
how much I enjoyed this movie because I
saw some of the reviews going in and I
was like
I don't know what to expect and I feel
like critics are really over analyzing
this movie this is a film made for the
60 to 80 demographic to go to the
theater and smile for 96 minutes and
forget about their troubles and just
have some light-hearted soft easygoing
fun and I don't think there's anything
wrong with that I don't think this movie
had to be comically daring I don't think
it has to say anything this movie was
made to have fun and I did have fun
watching it even though I'm not the
target demographic I enjoyed watching
these three legends you know what four
legends on screen because an Margaret is
fantastic and she's been around for a
very long time once the main heist
starts I would say the movie loses some
steam after that I was interested
because I actually did feel a connection
with these characters but it does taper
down a little bit in regards to
entertainment value the film does follow
a lot of the basic character tropes you
would expect for a movie like this some
older people are losing their pensions
to get to the man type stuff they have
families to care for one of them sick
you know all the stuff you would kind of
expect an older man's having a really
romantic fling and all of a sudden he
feels like a kid again you've seen all
these tropes before but they're handled
in a way that's respectful and simply
enjoyable
this is as I said a light-hearted very
easygoing movie that if it came on TV at
1:00 p.m. on Wednesday afternoon and it
was raining outside you had nothing else
to do I could see this film entertaining
you all so I just want to say after I
saw this movie I was thinking to myself
it's kind of hilarious this is like the
third in the unofficial Morgan Freeman
is old let's do some fun shit trilogy
the bucket list Last Vegas and now going
inside he's like he's made his own
unofficial trilogy of I'm dying let's go
do something crazy I enjoy myself at
going in style these three actors have
incredible chemistry's one another
there's really nothing to expect beyond
some light-hearted and fun jokes and I
found myself laughing and having a good
time I'm going to give going in style of
B guys thank you so much as always for
watching please look forward to this
Sunday because I'm going to finally be
able to review Donnie Darko which is a
film that I have a lot to say about and
it's been a favorite of mine for many
years the 4k restoration is in theaters
now and it's
finally coming to my area at the
night-light theater in Akron Ohio and I
am so excited to see the new restoration
and finally review it for you guys thank
you so much as always for watching and
if you like this you can click right
here and get stuck the nice
[Music]